WHAT'S GOOD FOR YOU, BOY,
YOU GONNA KEEP YOUR
HANDS OFF MY WOMAN.
YOUR WOMAN?
I SAW HER FIRST!
- PUTTING YOUR HANDS ON ME.
DON'T YOU PUT YOUR HANDS ON ME!
- DON'T YOU PUT YOUR HANDS
ON HER.
THAT'S MY WOMAN!
- YES!
-[jazz music]
-AND NOW...
FOR THE SCAT STYLINGS OF
REX "THE BONE DADDY" RONSON
AND TEDDY "12 COMBS" LEWIS.
both: ♪ ZOO DO DWEEP
BODO DWAPE, ZOODO DWEEP ♪
♪ ZODO BA DATIN WOP WOP
WA WOP WOW ♪
- ♪ BUTT, BUTT, BUTT,
BUTT, BUTT, BUTT, BUTT, BUTT ♪
♪ HOPPY GEEBO DERPA DAY ♪
♪ YOUR BREATH SMELLS
LIKE A BUTT ♪
♪ YOUR BOP BOP, BOOTY BOP ♪
♪ YOUR WHOLE MOUTH SMELLS LIKE
AN OPEN ASS ♪
♪ BUTT, POOP, POO ♪
- ♪ WAY WE VWEE VWAY,
FAT, FAT, WAT DWAY ♪
♪ FATTY USED TO CHEWBY DOO
YOU'RE FAT ♪
♪ YOU'RE A FAT, FAT ♪
FAT, FAY, FAY, BA BOO FATTY ♪
♪ FAH BOO BAH, FE, FI, FO FUM ♪
♪ WHAT DO I SMELL
BUT SOME FAT NEXT TO ME ♪
♪ THAT'S THE MAN, FATTY MM ♪
♪ POTTY FOO FAY FE, FO, FAT ♪
- ♪ HIDDLE BIT LITTLE BIT
DIBBIDY DOBBIDY DOO LA LA DA ♪
♪ TEENILY WEENILY HODDILY
HIDDILY LITTLA BITTLA ♪
♪ BABY PENIS ♪
♪ ♪
- ♪ FEEL FREE TO SUCK IT ♪
♪ SUCK IT AND SUCK IT
AND SUCK IT ♪
♪ AND SUCK IT
AND SUCK IT AND SUCK IT ♪
♪ FEEL FREE TO SUCK IT ♪
♪ FEEL FREE TO SUCK IT
FEEL FREE TO SUCK IT ♪
YOU CAN SUCK IT ♪
♪ AND PUT IT IN
IN YOUR MOUTH ♪
- ♪ STOP, MOP ♪
♪ YOUR FACE, YOUR FACE,
YOUR FACE ♪
♪ LOOKS LIKE A BALL SACK ♪
♪ NO WRINKLE DINKLE DOOS
STICKY DOOP ♪
♪ BA DEE DO, WRINKLE
DINKLE DEE DEE BALL SACK ♪
- [scatting]
♪ TELLENUM, TELLENUM, TEN OH,
TEN, YOU A TAINT, YOU A TAINT ♪
♪ YOU'RE A TAINT
YOU'RE A TAINT ♪
♪ THE SPACE
BETWEEN THE BUTT AND BALLS ♪
♪ TAINT FACE, YOU TAINTY TAINT
YOUR FACE IS A TAINT, TAINT ♪
♪ TAINT, TAINT ♪
- ♪ TAKE IT BACK ♪
- ♪ NO, I WON'T ♪
- ♪ I NEVER WILL ♪
- ♪ TAKE IT BACK ♪
- ♪ NO, I WON'T, NEVER WILL ♪
- ♪ TAKE IT BACK, TAKE IT BACK ♪
- ♪ TAKE IT BACK ♪
- ♪ NO, I WON'T ♪
both: ♪ 'CAUSE YOU'RE
A SON OF A, SON OF A ♪
♪ SON OF A, SON OF A BITCH,
BITCH, BITCH ♪
♪ SON OF A, SON OF A, SON OF A,
SON OF A BITCH, BITCH, BITCH ♪
[cheers and applause]
- ♪ YOU DON'T NEED
TO FIGHT OVER ME ♪
♪ THERE'S PLENTY
OF THE VA-GA- ♪
[scatting]
♪ GINA ♪
♪ VAGINA ♪
♪ THERE'S PLENTY OF, OF, OF ♪
YOU KNOW WHAT
I'M TALKING ABOUT, RIGHT?
[laughs]
Y'ALL KNOW WHAT
I'M TALKING ABOUT.